FBI director Christopher Ray getting
squeezed like a lemon by Republican
lawmakers up on Capitol Hill Rays
sitting there for hours and struggling
to defend a long list of Bureau misdeeds
including political bias weaponization
of government power and whether the
bidens are getting off easy
are you protecting the bidens
absolutely not the FBI idea you won't
answer the question about whether or not
that's a Shakedown and everybody knows
why you won't answer it are you or your
staff auxiliaries weaponizing the FBI
against the American people
absolutely not the idea that I'm biased
against conservatives
seems somewhat insane to me a ballroom a
bathroom a bedroom are those appropriate
places to store classified confidential
information there are specific rules
about where to store classified
information and that those need to be
stored in a skiff how about a box in a
in a Mr chairman beach house in Delaware
in the Biden Center I don't think those
are skills Mr chairman and listen to
this eyebrow raising moment over whether
the Delaware attorney who gave hunter
that sweetheart deal is investigating
President Biden
did Joe Biden take payments from barisma
or any other foreign companies as vice
president president or private citizen
Biden as you may know there is an
ongoing investigation being led by the
U.S attorney in Delaware and I would
refer you to to him as to what if
anything can be so the president is
under
um he is under
um investigation I'm not going to
confirm or speak to who is or isn't
under investigation as usual instead of
just doing journalism MSNBC would rather
mock the GOP for investigating the Biden
family
all they do is humiliate themselves uh
and again I keep wondering at some point
there are I know for a fact there are
Republicans right now in the house who
are going somebody step in and stop this
because we're all looking like a bunch
of morons
wow Jennifer Rubin really got some work
done
and it looks 20 years younger all right
judge from your perspective how did he
do
did we get anywhere on this one
we didn't get anywhere but I'll tell you
what is what his Mo was his Mo was to
say he doesn't know that much about
what's going on and therefore when they
ask him specifically he can say well I
don't have all the information on that I
can get back to you on that however it
was so infuriating irrespective of what
those people were saying in terms of uh
how ridiculous the people on the right
look the truth is that I think he has
given everybody a little more evidence
for an impeachment okay whether or not
they go through with it or not I don't
know but let me tell you what happened
here he was asked about the fisa court
being abused and he and he was asked how
many times has the fisa court illegally
spied on Americans now the first thing
out of his mouth should have been well
Jim Comey did on Carter page during that
election but he said quote I have no
idea his own Inspector General
criticized the FBI and they said there
were hundreds even at a Adler Jerry
Nadler said that there were hundreds
okay then he was asked about the mark
Howe case that uh right to lifer and he
said they said are you familiar he said
well a little bit and then they talked
about how local authorities wouldn't
bring a case the feds did the jury came
back in less than an hour of not guilty
and then when they start criticizing
that going in the fed's going in uh with
guns and helicopters to this family
um he says no he said the people
involved had 40 years of experience they
were career agents and they came to the
door they did not storm the door and all
of a sudden in order to defend the FBI
he knows all the specifics which he said
in the beginning he knew very little of
and January 6th what do you know about
the covert agents I really need to be
careful here talking about what whether
we have or have not used confidential
human sources I just can't speak to that
it wouldn't answer that either as
opposed to saying no okay that's got
turned up the burner and finally with
respect to that recent court case where
the court has stopped the FBI
specifically as an agency contacting the
social media companies they said does
the FBI get involved in a massive effort
to suppress information and
Communications he said absolutely not
it's ludicrous we're not in the business
of suppressing and they then said but
the judge himself found that the FBI
suppressed millions of citizens
Communications around the election time
so this guy is nothing more than a paper
tiger and someone who is I think in the
left camp with nothing to nothing to say
that he's done well he did the same
thing too with the about Bank of America
uh or find other financial institutions
supplying information on people who were
there on January 6 not just just in D.C
and he said he had no idea and then when
they actually bring it up because oh
that story oh yeah well maybe we had
some backup but so he always says I
don't know and then when you say well
here's the evidence because oh that
stuff yeah that happened that I just
didn't know it Dana does this depress
you like you're an idealist like I turn
it I get very depressed because I like
the FBI of course I was watching you
know today especially
um
Nadler starts the nadler's the Democrat
on the ranking side over opposite of
Jordan and he says you know years ago
this hearing would have been more
bipartisan and that's true and there are
bipartisan committees now like for
example the one on China the one on AI
several of the ones even on energy
believe it or not on Health Care there's
a lot of cooperation but this committee
there's a lot of animosity I don't like
watching that necessarily I also don't
think this is a great model that five
minutes of questioning you know that
it's a situation where he's under oath
he's going to say he doesn't know
there's so many things that are still
under investigation and I'm wondering at
some point could we get to a position
where the FBI director says okay
we're sorry here's three things that we
did we shouldn't have done and here's
three things we're going to do to make
it better and let's all try to agree on
that and move on maybe there's
consequences for people that are okay
because we need strong law enforcement
because we have a lot of problems
they're they're not only dealing with
domestic issues they're supposed to do
with foreign threats as well and we want
people good people to go into the FBI
and to feel like it's a fulfilling
career and right now I don't know if
they're feeling that way though he did
try to defend the men and women of the
FBI yeah that's the thing that kind of
bugged me when I was watching this like
is this another one of those things
where it goes nowhere you know each
person is burning the clock so they
don't really say anything Jesse it
reminds me a lot of you on your show
so much yeah and then I never let the
let the Finish yes yes and then you got
to go to
so when you're the FBI director what you
do is you investigate everything so that
you can say when asked that I'm sorry I
can't talk it's under investigation
you're investigating still January 6th
the bidens the trumps Hunter the pipe
bomber the parents at school boards
Muslims and antifa it's all under
investigation
and so you're never going to get them to
answer anything under oath about what
he's doing and then if you ask him and
you got him dead to write to you guys I
don't know I'm sorry up maybe and then
so you get nowhere Gates did a pretty
nice job he brought the drama not
everybody did the best job the fisa
things really bad you're right judge I
mean they're basically using fisa to spy
on ex-girlfriends yeah
Flynn yep I can only imagine I'm just
not going to go there I am reading a
book okay
oh
it's not yours
at Charles Manson and the murders and
you'd be surprised at how many FBI
agents military intelligence and and CIA
Ops were swirling around the Manson
family and they were in San Francisco
and then they were in the valley and
it's it's almost unbelievable you think
back then in the 60s
you had the feds involved in these
things and four or five decades later
they're still have their fake dirty
little fingers in every single
controversy in every single scandal in
the United States and they still get
away with it what paid you on I finished
it oh wow you actually did it good read
the whole thing wow good for you not The
Hobbit yes no no no no no no not the
prosecutor's book He's the bad guy the
prosecutors
he convicted Charlie Manson the whole
group he's a bad guy it was a cover-up
the Mansion trial was a cover-up didn't
do it oh he did it he had his people do
it it was but the reason why you got to
read the book Harold take a look right
now take a look there I am on TV right
now
I've been on that in that corner look at
me yes yes it was more spectacle uh when
I was in Congress to Dana's point when
Congress exercises oversight it's a
really really good thing
[Laughter]
it's democrat or republican I just hope
that I don't know what the American
people got out of that uh I think Matt
Gates I disagree with you there Jess I
thought it was a great spectacle it was
a great campaign moment for him but if
you wanted to know the reforms the guy
has has made if you wanted to know what
monies he may need to fight other things
he they found no they found that serial
killer out in the West Coast
well we should give them credit for
things that they're doing I think
Parkland how about Nasser how about all
the messes they've done
look no one's perfect no I'm not
defending that I don't know what the
committee got out of this other than
made you upset you're now upset with me
for no reason I'm just trying to State
when I was in Congress oversight was
there was an intention that sure there
was a purpose to it this here only had a
political purpose not a subset policy
purpose there you have it
Harold Ford defending Charles Manson
never thought I would say that I did not
defend Michigan how dare you put words
in my mouth how dare you talk to me like
that I'll talk to you however I did well
please okay
I think this bug at the bottom over
there is making us crazy
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is
leeway that I know for sure that you're
not going to miss any great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on Fox you
can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now